no solo continúan sino que parece que
han vuelto a tomar aire y es que después
de esa ceremonia de los 40 días después
del fallecimiento de maxamming donde
Vimos a miles y miles de personas
recordarlas en el resto de Irán donde
también hubo protestas pero
especialmente en el kurdistán iraní de
donde ella era originaria seguimos en
los días posteriores viendo protestas en
esta región del país ese día el día de
la conmemoración de la muerte de maxa
hubo un fallecido en la ciudad de
magebán y allí ayer hubo un gran funeral
para recordarlo donde miles y miles de
personas protestaron y rodearon algunos
edificios gubernamentales recibiendo una
gran represión de las fuerzas de
seguridad que intentaron impedirlo Y eso
también sucedió en otras ciudades del
kurdistán iraní también sucedía en un
momento en el que se volvía a recordar
la muerte de otra joven esta vez de 16
años nicachaharani que había participado
en las protestas pero su cuerpo
desapareció darte una semana hasta que
fue entregado a su familia argumentando
que había cometido suicidio sin embargo
hay bastantes vídeos que demuestran que
ese día que desapareció la niña estaba
en las calles protestando y esto sucede
también cuando la confusión Y el dolor
por esa masacre que sucedió el miércoles
pasado en una gran mausoleo en la ciudad
de chiras que dejó 15 muertos y 40
heridos sigue creando preguntas de Por
qué sucedió esto que el estado islámico
dice que lo cometieron tres de sus
hombres aquí en las autoridades han
dicho que las protestas han abierto el
camino para que haya inseguridad y crear
ese tipo de atentados de organizaciones
terroristas sin embargo para intentar
llamar la atención hoy el gobierno ha
creado o llamó a una serie de
movilizaciones que se dieron a las
afueras de la oración de los viernes con
miles y miles de personas Donde fueron
convocadas repito por el estado